ونحيكم من جديد الحرب اليمنيه قسمت
المناطق والطرقات وقسمت السيطره على
الموانئ والمطارات كما قسمت الاقتصاد في
البلاد الى منطقتين اقتصاديتين بعد انهيار
محادثات السلام عام 2016 نقلت الحكومه مقر
البنك المركزي اليمني من صنعاء التي يسيطر
عليه الخوثيون الى عاصمتها المؤقته في عدن
لكن الحوثيين رفضوا هذا القرار في حينه
فتوقفت رواتب الموظفين تلهى انقسام اداره
البنك المركزيه العليا الى ثلاثه اجزاء في
صنعاء وهي تابعه للحوثيين وعدم التابعه
للحكومه واداره ثالثه تابعه للحكومه في
محافظه مارب ويقول باحثون يمنيون ان
الطباعه البنك المركزي عمله ورقيه جديده
من فئه الف ريال بمواصفات مختلفه من دون
غطاء نقدي لمواجهه ازمه السيوله تسبب في
انهيار الريال اليمني بمناطق سيطره
الحكومه اليمنيه حينها اعلن الحوثيون منع
تداول العمله الجديده في مناطق سيطره هالي
تدخل ازمه الانقسام النقدي مرحله جديده من
الانقسام الحاد بين عملتين باسعار مختلفه
للعمله المحليه اثقلت كاهلا اليمنيين اعود
من جديد الى ضيوفه سيد بدر موضوع سعر صرف
العمله موضوع البنك المركزي موضوع
تمكين الموانئ من التحرر كما يطالب
اليمنيون كل هذا هل سيدفع عجله الاقتصاد
في الداخل اليمني
دعيني فقط اوضح نقطه كانت في
السابقلين سيتم تبادل 800
[موسيقى]
اسير ومعتقل من الطرفين كخطوه اولى وليس
15 الف الذي كان من المفترض ان يكون سياسه
الكل مقابل الكل فقط لكي نكون دقيقين
وهذا وهذا على فكره ذكرناه سيد بدر نحن
ذكرناه في المقدمه قلنا بانه 700 واكثر من
جانب الشرعيه يعني هم حوثيون يتبعون
الحوثيين و 181 اعتقد من الجانب المقابل
هذه المرحله الاولى ولكن نحن نتحدث عن
الاف والاكيد ستاتي مراحل اخرى
نتحدث عن الجانب الاقتصادي
الحوثيون يطالبون بتحرير الموانئ وهي خطوه
يعني تعتبر اساسيه لدى لديهم او في موقفهم
هذه النقطه هل يمكن ان تدير عجله الاقتصاد
تعتقد يعني انا اسمي هذه
الازمه هي صراع الاقتصاد السياسي في اليمن
مساله تحرير الموانئ هي مصطلح يستخدمها
الحوثيون لكي يشير الى شاحنات شاحنات
النفط التي تدخل الى الحديده بالتحديد
والتي منها قيادات حوثيه ولا تلتزم
بالشروط التي وضعتها الحكومه اليمنيه ولا
تتضايق الجماعه كثيرا من اليه التفتيش
الامميه المختصره او المختزل بكلمه انظم
هذه نقطه مساله الاقتصاد مهمه جدا نحن
راينا كيف كانت السعوديه
ربما
تجاوزت المساعدات 22 مليار دولار
لليمن هذا بالاضافه الى الودائع والمنح
التي حاولت الحفاظ على العمله المشكله في
اليمن كما تفضلتي مساله العمله الحوثيون
يجبرون الصرافين في صنعاء على الابقاء على
سعر صرف محدد وبالتالي
التضخم بلغ اعلى داخل مناطق الحوثيين
لانهم لا يستطيعون ان يديروا اقتصادا او
دوله باي شكل من الاشكال وكما تفضلت هناك
عتب من المراقبين على الحكومه اليمنيه
حينما طبعت العمله مساله توحيد البنك
اجريت مقابله مع اول محافظ للبنك المركزي
كما نقل
في 2016 وكانت الحكومه اليمنيه وقتها
مجبره الان بوسط هذه الاجواء التصالحيه
اعتقد انها فرصه مهمه لبناء الثقه ولتحفيز
الجميع لانه عندما يتوحد البنك المركزي
سوف ينعكس ذلك على سعر الصرف سوف ينعكس
حتى على اسعار كل شيء حتى غاز الطهي تخيلي
في مناطق الحوثيين سوف تنخفض اسعارهم
لانهم يشترون من الحكومه اليمنيه سعر ارخم
تداول المشتقات النفطيه في السوق السوداء
وبكل تاكيد الخطوه الاخيره في في التي
تمثلت في تحرير 500 من السلع المزدوجه
مزدوجه الاستخدام كانت مؤشر جيد ونتمنى ان
يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق النار لكي يمهد
سريعا لبقيه الملفات خصوصا وقف اطلاق
النار هو الذي سيرتب كل هذا او سيسهل كل
هذا استاذ سالم حضرتك مطلع على بعض
التفاصيل اضافيه هل يمكن القول بانه تم
الاتفاق على توحيد العمله ان يتخلى
على العمله انشاها بتطور هذه الاحداث في
مقابل ان يعود مركز البنك المركزي الى
صنعاء
يعني ترك ذلك
لجان فنيه او لجنه فنيه تقيم هذا الامر في
توحيد البنك المصرفي خلال المرحله المقبله
وهذه خطوه لاحقه صحيحه اتفق بانها خطوه
يجب ان تكون في البدايات لكن ذلك يحتاج
الى المزيد من الوقت لكن التوافق على
توحيد العمله والتوافق على ايضا ان يكون
هناك مقر واحد للبنك المركزي اضافه الى
بعض الافرع مستقبلا او حاليا هذا امر قائم
وامر متفهم من الاطراف ومن الضروره جدا ان
يتم هذا العمل بشكل جيد بين الجميع حتى
يمكن ان تكون العمله هي المحرك الاساسي
للاقتصاد وان يكون لها سعر صرف واحد ولها
اجراءات واحده وكذلك التعامل ايضا مع
المنظمات الدوليه الماليه ذكرت منذ قليل
سيد سالم وقلت بانه تم الاتفاق على
الموانع مطر صنعاء وهذا سيحفز كذلك حتى
عمل الجهات الامميه
وذكرتهن سؤال دكتور علي الى اي مدى العمل
على الموانئ ومطار صنعاء
وايجاد حلول
بخصوصهما يمكن ان يمثل الدفع
لتجنيد المجتمع الدولي لمساعده الاطراف
اليمنيه بالداخل
من زاويه الحكومه اليمنيه هي
اظهرت هذا منذ مده طويله استعدادها فعلا
للفتح الفتح
صنعاء وفتح
بناء الحديده وكان في الفتره السابقه طبعا
المحاذير في ظروف الحرب هي من دخول من
تهريب السلاح الايراني الى المليشيات
الحوثيه
وايضا استخدام المطار ليس الى اغراض
البدنيه ولكن ايضا استخدامه للاغراض
العسكريه هذا هو كان سبب الرقابه التي
كانت مفروضه على المطار وعلى
ترتيبات اخرى هو في كل الحالات ساعتذر
منكم لانه انتهى تماما توقيت هذه الحلقه
ولكن الاكيد باننا سنعود الى تفاصيل اخرى
القاكم في حلقات اخرى من بانوراما من مسقط
سالم الجهوري صحفي وباحث في شؤون الدوليه
من لندن بدر القحطاني محرر الملف اليمني
في جريده الشرق الاوسط من القاهره دكتور
علي الصراريا المستشار الاعلاميه لرئيس
الوزراء اليمني من الرياض محمد العمده
مستشار وامين العاصمه صنعاء ورئيس شبكه
اليمنيه للحقوق والحريات هذا الموضوع فيه
تفاصيل اخرى نناقشها في حلقه قادمه السلام
عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات